is growing alarm in the u.s over the
impact of vaccine hesitancy
and vaccine refusal on the fight to beat
the coronavirus
in 16 states less than half the
population has received at least one
dose
our coverage this week brought us to
arkansas where hospitals were filling up
with younger covet patients
we also visited louisiana and spoke to
an unvaccinated patient
who said he still would not get the shot
and today
we're in nevada which has the highest
rate of positive cova tests nationwide
our lilia luciano saw a new effort to
respond to the crisis
lilia good morning good morning to you
vlad
that plus the low vaccination rates
pushed the governor
to specifically request for assistance
from the byte administration
and as you said we were there with one
of these coveted search response teams
as they work with local groups to try to
curb cases
at this pop-up clinic in las vegas
barbara collins-gibbons is trying to get
her first covid vaccine
givens and her husband both had coveted
earlier this month
so while they have to wait a while to
get vaccinated she's telling everyone to
get the shot
now they're all gonna get it because i
told them they need to get it
that's exactly what officials want to
happen it really has become
a pandemic of the unvaccinated health
and human services secretary javier
becerra says community outreach is the
key to curbing rising cases
and deaths is it lack of access in
certain communities to vaccinations or
lack of confidence
in the vaccines that you're working
against well it's a little bit of both
but for our purposes it doesn't make any
difference we want to support those
who want to get out there and get those
unvaccinated with the vaccine
the clinic is run by local and state
personnel working alongside the newly
dispatched federal covet surge
response team they're going to
concentrate on the lowest
vaccination rate areas first and work
their way up
the groups identify specific community
hot spots then go into those areas to
promote vaccinations
we try to improve those rates so we can
save lives
blocks away on the vegas strip both
unvaccinated
and vaccinated workers are masking up
again after county officials passed the
mandate for all indoor employees
but the tens of millions of annual
tourists can continue to be maskless
how is the public protected i mean we're
indoors and there is
so much traffic of unmasked people we're
pumping in up to 100 percent
outside fresh air at all times and doing
an air cycle ball every five to six
minutes
mgm resorts vice president of health and
safety strategy john flynn
gave us a rare look inside the aria
hotel and casino
we know that the cleaner air that we
could pump in here it's going to
greatly deter the spread for our
employees and for our guests too the
hotel is even offering pop-up
vaccination clinics and cova testing to
help protect their employees we want to
try to get
every single person vaccinated the more
people we can get vaccinated
the sooner we can put this pandemic
behind us
tourists indoors are out vaccinated or
unvaccinated don't need to wear masks in
anthony
very few people are choosing to do so to
try and keep cases down las vegas is
offering perks
anywhere from a shot for a shot free
drinks to concert tickets that are free
for people who choose to get vaccinated
here a shot for a shot lily i like that
thank you very much
our